this next actress is so beautiful and so
talented she's one of the great movie
stars of this generation and there's
nothing bad you can say about her
however I did hear this last week she
got all liquored up stole Elan boy and
tried to mow her pool and yet if you ask
her about it
she'll deny it here she is America's
Sweetheart Julia Roberts
since I took so long to walk across that
fine stage I'm just going to cut to the
chase and say I'm here to present
cinematographer and if it weren't for a
great cinematographers would all be in
radio the nominees are
Peter Powell for Crouching Tiger Hidden
Dragon John Matheson for gladiator la
host cult I from Elena Roger Deakins for
oh brother where art thou Caleb
Deschanel for the Patriot
hope it's a name I can pronounce in real
life the Oscar goes to
Peter pal
this is the first Academy Award and
nomination for Peter pal
I'm going to speak very fast I would
like to thank Ann Lee for giving me this
once-in-a-lifetime chance I must thank
all my friends including turbo juicers
I'll you are don't puke on Phillip Lee
James Schumer swamp wailing phone pings
resuming Charles Wang Tony I billing
Michael Barker Tom Barnard in his team
Charlie Infante Michelle Yeoh Changsha
eat and pay pay Taunton David Lee Leola
Mannix deluxe Toronto lastly deep breath
in crystal sovereign David Kirsch in
Melanie Ramseyer my parent my sisters my
mentors I mean that for giving me
spiritual guidance for over 15 years
my entire camera in lighting crew in
Hong Kong in China including Kenny lamp
Leigh taxing Louis Jeong Jimmy for
choice on fake often when lamb Coleman I
must thank the Academy giving me this
award tonight it's a great honor to me
to the people of Hong Kong and Chinese
people all over the world thank you very
much
a special award to be presented by Oscar
winner Dustin Hoffman and Academy Award
nominee Kate Hudson
you